and look how quick anisha's moving with
his mouse the black rook moved and
white's rook also shuffling across this
must be when blunder has happened it's
crazy on the clock i see a lot of
blunders black meanwhile has grabbed the
pawn blacks a porn up but look at
white's rook suddenly white's rooks are
dominant taking over and aneesh he's
pretty much pre-moving at this stage
he's just using the mouse putting pieces
on squares and oh maybe he missed this
one black's knight jumping back to
attack white's rook and white's rook
forced to retreat suddenly white's
knight on the edge of the board on the
top of the board
looked good but stranded
and okay dude are trying to repeat the
position
and he says no he'll draw not good
enough for white
and white king running this one is super
fast
day is just blitzing out the moose
[Music]
was it checkmate it was checkmate first
time wow and that means the niche gear
he loses the match he gains one point
for losing it and ty breaks two points
for young christophe duda
[Music]